a seat at the cabinet table brings great
responsibility but what happens when an
illness threatening the life of the
person closest to you turns your world
upside down I talked to James and Susie
cleverly about foreign policy teamwork
and dealing with cancer
[Music]
hello and welcome to Beth Rigby
interviews just four months ago the Nile
prime minister Rishi sunak resigned from
his position as Chancellor at the time
the government of Boris Johnson's
Premiership was engulfed by allegations
of sexual misconduct against the former
deputy chief whip Chris pincher later in
the show we hear from Lord McDonald a
former civil servant who rocked the
government by saying Mr Johnson's
defense that he didn't know about the
claims were untrue
but first for James cleverley being the
foreign secretary means dealing with
high pressure situations but like many
families his has been battling with
unimaginable pain his wife Susie who he
describes as his biggest support found
out she had breast cancer a year ago
this week we went on a special visit to
the foreign office to hear their story
um Susie and James thank you for joining
us on the show today now James you are
our foreign secretary running one of the
great offices of State for government
but we're not here to talk about foreign
policy today although I might ask you
one question at the end we're here to
talk about Susie actually more about
your wife Susie and about your battle
with cancer and you're looking great and
you look so well now but it has been
quite a torturous Journey
so thank you for sharing your story in
raising awareness for other women out
there and thank you for inviting us to
the beautiful foreign office but what I
wanted to do I thought what would be
nice would be to start at the beginning
because you two are renowned around
Westminster has been a very close couple
so let's start at the beginning how did
you both meet
we met at University it was the um my
first day of my first year and James was
working behind the bar
and I just met these new friends you
know and I was trying to impress them I
went to buy all the drinks and James
served me and um
and I and I waited a while to get my
drinks you're a bit slow because he told
everybody don't serve her I wanna I
wanna serve her and I took all the
drinks and I went off and I didn't
really pay much attention I was just so
focused on you know my new friends and
um but you followed me didn't you and I
did and came to chat to me pretty cheesy
chat up line what was that I basically
said you've got the most gorgeous eyes
I've ever seen in my life right in front
of her friends on her first day at Uni
yeah but she she does still does and and
they all kind of went oh and just left
us to it and and that was it and that
was it that was 29 years ago and you
just that was it you started going out
and that was it
uh nearly so this was lovely from our
site James
yeah I mean yeah I mean I mean Susie was
and is absolutely stunning managed to
forget my wallet on our first date so as
soon as you had to pay for our first six
packages
so I did my best to screw it up but I
think no it's yeah
and 29 years in your you know you've
very much together you have two sons now
adults I think uh Rupert's just turned
18 your younger boy
um and James you were a minister in the
Johnson Administration back in 2021 your
boys were were growing up and then
everything changed for for you and your
entire family Susie when did you first
learn you were ill
it's almost a year to the day actually a
year ago on Sunday it was 13th of
November we were in Essex and I just got
up in the morning went to have a shower
and I was just letting the water run and
you know to get warm yeah and I just did
An Almighty stretch in front of the
mirror and and as I came back out up
from the stretch I just noticed
just really really was luck I noticed
the strange puckering on my skin
underneath my breast and I instantly
knew that's not right that's never been
there before so I went into James and
said have you seen this have you seen
this before and he was like No And we
were both like
this isn't this isn't right
but it was Saturday morning what can you
do on a Saturday morning so we just
thought let's just park it and enjoy our
weekend and the constituency and we had
we had quite a few events on I think
there was a remember it was a
remembrance Sunday weekend so we had a
number of things that we were going to
there and um I thought well I'll just
ring the doctors on the Monday morning
and that's what I did
and I nearly I nearly didn't it was just
James's look look at me on the Monday
morning he
you know we were busy it was what it's
like in the morning with getting
everybody ready the dogs
kids all sorts and um James looked at me
and said don't forget to call the doctor
okay and he was so serious
and I just felt I need to and I did and
it all happened so quickly and it did
happen quickly so so that's November the
13th you noticed a puckering on your
breast yeah you phoned the doctor Monday
and then your diagnosis happened quite
quickly what's the third of December
yeah that I mean what so what was the
process I mean were you you must have
been were you frightened or did you just
try and put it to the back of your mind
and wait to see what the doctor said I
think the day I was really frightened
with the day I went to the doctor
because I knew something wasn't right
and okay and I I knew that puckering was
a sign for breast cancer and I I went to
my GP and I told him they were they were
amazing the reception said why you why
do you want to see the doctor and I said
explained what I'd found and she said
the doctor will need to see you today
the doctor will ring you between half
past eight and twelve at half past eight
on the dot the doctor rang me and said I
need to see you today when I explained
what it was and I said that's fine I can
be there in two minutes because we live
a few houses up from the doctors so I
whized round before he even started his
surgery and within seconds I was you
know he examined me he could feel a lump
I couldn't feel a lump right and he
could see the puckering of the skin and
he he said for what I can see and what I
can feel I think you do have breast
cancer but I'm going to refer you to the
breast clinic
take somebody with you it's probably
going to be bad news and okay I think
that's what he said
yeah you know I don't know because you
suddenly get hit by this
oh it's cancer
um and I don't really know if those were
the words but that's what I what I heard
and what I remember and I just came out
of there and I rang James who was on the
train into Westminster to here and
um I said I think it's cancer and I just
burst into tears and I think I cried
most of that day because it was a bit of
a shock and that was the time I was
really really scared yeah but then you
kind of you get used well I just got
used to it it's cancer
what can I do I can't do anything I've
just got to do as I'm told take the
medication and then
get there so you've got you've very well
James what did you do you're coming into
work and seriously friends with this
bomber show and you've what you have to
go and just do your days what I mean it
must have been yeah it was it was uh it
was quite weird so we'd come back to
London
um because I was you know going to be
coming into Westminster as we as we
often do so I've got on the Suburban
train
to head into Westminster and
my plan had been Susie goes to the
doctor hopefully it's nothing to worry
about and I get on with my day
and Susie rang me and she said I've been
see the doctor they're not happy they
think it might be cancer
and I said I'll come home I'll I'll turn
straight around I'll I'll come home so I
had to ring my private secretary at the
foreign office say look can you cancel
my meetings because I need to go home
and and he said is everything okay
Minister and I I tried to say
Susie might have cancer I I just
couldn't get the words out I I couldn't
speak
and I can talk
um but I just couldn't speak so I said
I'll text you and I texted him
um and you know this organization was
amazing Liz truss was my boss at the
time when she was front actually she's
absolutely amazing
um and um and you know so councilman
meetings and went home talked to Susie
we talked it through I then tried to
ring again to explain what was going on
and I still I couldn't say it I couldn't
say the word I couldn't say the word so
for the next couple of hours everything
was done on on on WhatsApp just
explaining you know apologizing for
meetings that was canceled
um and it really hit me and I hadn't I'd
never felt anything like that before
I and because I was going to say Susie
the thing was you you got diagnosed very
quickly but it was it was an aggressive
cancer yeah yeah and three types of
breast cancer I didn't know you could
get three three types I didn't know so
what are they did you have the most
aggressive time I had I'm triple
positive
um so it responds to my hormones and her
too is Eastern progesterone and her too
and her too
is um I think that's the aggressive one
and ten years ago there was no cure for
her too so I'm really fortunate that I
got it now the most frightening thing
was the word cancer yeah yeah
as soon as that was kind of
I was on board that I had cancer it yeah
and you've just got to go through it
through it but I wasn't scared when they
told me that I had but James you sort of
said how you couldn't actually even
verbalize what was happening to Susie
and the family you know you you've got
your sons your very tight family I mean
was this the fast serious trauma the
family had had I mean was it the worst
thing that had happened to you both as a
couple would you say or
I can't remember
I mean we've I've always regarded
myself as being lucky
um and that's not it's not that I
haven't had difficulties
um I mean my mum had breast cancer it's
quite funny it almost
you know so mum had breast cancer mum
passed away about seven eight years ago
nine years ago
um and you know it's we've had
difficulties in our life I mean like a
lot of people when we were a bit younger
um you know I I got made redundant at
one point so money was tight so you've
had we've had difficulties but you know
we have got a really really supportive
extended family on both both my side and
Susie's side so we've always been able
to get through but this
I mean this this this was different it
really did feel different and Susie
you're as the disease progressed it was
rough wasn't it can you talk to me a
little bit about that that Journey for
you because your treatment became almost
on Battle it did become unbearable
didn't it in terms of the side effects
for you it did it was I mean don't get
me wrong people do get it far worse than
I had it but it was I it was really
tough
um I the first drug I was on
it hit me really hard every time I had
it I had it four times and it was every
two weeks and I would come home and two
hours later I'd be knocked out not I'd
have to go straight to bed I knew I had
to go to bed and I was I was quite ill
with it but I would slowly slowly get
better and over the couple of weeks I'd
slowly kind of feel like I was climbing
out of the hole and then you have to do
the next round and then you're hit again
but yeah if you did four lots of that
and then they moved you on to a
different drug didn't you yeah which was
part of the plan I was going on to
another drug
um called Dace taxil for another four
doses every three weeks
but I had a reaction to that and my face
um all sorts of I had a whole long list
of side effects but yeah my nails
they're all the reason they're painted
is because they're all black and falling
off I've lost two of my toenails
um and the sensitivity on my fingers is
horrible and my feet but with that drug
my face bloomed and um I was covered in
hives that became infected and
it was really really quite uncomfortable
and it looked pretty awful didn't I and
it was itchy and it was wasn't very nice
and they took me off it I also had
problems with my stomach and he also
talked about when we talked the other
day actually I saw your particle you
talked about and my friends having
treatment at the moment she's having the
same about the ulcers in the mouth yes
you couldn't even eat or drink at one
point no that's right I couldn't and I
could it was very difficult to speak I
look back at some videos I've done
because I'm doing a video diary
and um yeah I couldn't speak I couldn't
move my tongue properly around my mouth
because my mouth was so sore
um and putting even putting a glass of
water to my lips was really painful the
water going in my mouth was really
painful it was yeah it was not nice did
you I know it's a you just have to go
through it don't you because you need to
get better but you must have felt quite
low did you withdraw you you did you
withdraw from Life a bit did you hide
away I mean how did you cope with that
well I didn't really do a huge amount
because I couldn't really do very much I
but I did walk my dogs every day
um and people would come and visit I had
a lot of support from family and friends
there was always somebody coming to see
me so I didn't go out a lot but I had a
lot of people coming to help me help me
around the house help me in the garden
um people cooked for me people would
turn up with meals and the support has
been absolutely incredible really really
incredible and and James for you you're
here at the foreign office when this is
happening you're working as a minister
did you at any point think I'm going to
have to take some compassionate leave or
even quit my job like I need to politics
is frenetic it never stops the demands
on you never stop did you think actually
Susie needs me more than the foreign
office needs me right now
so I I said to to Susie
um I I will do whatever I need to do and
I've and and Susie's always had a veto
on on my political career that's we I've
always said this can be really really
horrible and if at any point we had this
conversation long before the cancer I
always said if at any point you don't
want me to do this anymore
that's it I'll stop I'll I'll hand in my
papers and I'll stop
um and and so when this happened I you
know I said look I you know I
what do you want me to do and and Susie
said well look you know just keep keep
working
until I I you know I need you to stop
working and say Liz was great and had a
conversation with Liz and I said look
this is a situation I want to keep
working but at some point and it might
be a quite short notice I'm gonna I
might need to take some time off and she
said look
keep working as normal until you can't
work as normal and then and then let me
know so she was she was great and as you
know the whips were great that you know
the PM was great
um
and I suppose trying to maintain some
normality in my life was was was was was
quite important but
um ultimately when when you went for
surgery uh and you did need a lot of
support you know getting dressed and
um and and walking and that kind of
stuff I I took some time off
but I mean for Susie's
you know she's strong like iron she
really I mean I was I mean I look back
now as I was amazed by how little time I
needed to take off and how determined
you were to recover but I mean that
period immediately for that couple of
weeks after the surgery was
that was really nice yeah what happened
what happened tell me about this so you
had a I didn't expect it to me a single
mistake to me on the right side of
reconstruction at the same time and they
took my stomach yeah the breath
um but I I knew that that's when I'd
need him and I knew I wanted James to be
with me and and I knew it would take a
couple of weeks so that's why I just
wanted you to keep going
um and not be I didn't need him sitting
on you know worrying about me but the
surgery
the surgery was full on it was full on
but it's all manageable you know you
just you just
I didn't really think about it too much
I just did you did you think though did
you have moments where you thought am I
going to get through this am I going to
get better or did you always have it in
your mind that you will you would get
through it oh yeah I always thought I'd
get through it I I'm quite a positive
person I don't even think there's
another option
maybe at the beginning I was like oh
maybe this is it this is the end of my
road but as soon as I was on you know as
soon as I was seeing my consultant and I
was given my plan of the medication I
was going to be on I thought okay yeah
there's a there's a way out and and as I
say to people that it's like getting on
a roller coaster you just get on the
ride and you've got to go with it yeah
if you try and fight it that's when you
get into trouble and I don't I don't
look to the Future not because I don't
think there's going to be one for me not
at all it's just because I just need to
take each day as it comes and get
through those moments I mean one of the
things that that really struck me is
that we referred to guys and Thomas's
yeah uh Cancer Center
um and everybody all the various all the
various medical professionals from all
the various different teams and I lose
track of how many different bits of the
NHS work to do this every single one of
them were just incredibly professional
and that professionalism was just so
reassuring and and once people start
explaining this is what's happening this
is what we're going to you this is how
it's going to work this is what happens
next
you know even though they're talking
about quite scary stuff it was
incredibly reassuring it was remarkable
it's striking how many people you find
out have either had breast cancer or
have someone close to them that's got
breast cancer that was one of the things
so it's it's much more prevalent than
than
I realized and having someone you love
go through it makes it makes it real
James did you ever think you might lose
Susie in this journey or did you always
think she'll be okay that may be the day
you found out
there have been a couple of times when
when I've had to like think about that
um
and it's weird because you know when
you're younger you go through big chunks
of your life that's not there's not
anything you ever think about
um and I you know and I hadn't thought
about my own mortality and I certainly
haven't ever really given any thought to
losing Susie or
or what that might feel like and then
suddenly you've got to confront that
um
and as you say we are close
sorry
and
um the good thing is though the good
news is that you've had your treatment
and you've had your reconstruction
you've had your mastectomy and and how
are you now because you look great yeah
I feel great I feel so much more like me
I'm still having treatment I'm having
immunotherapy now and that'll be going
on until April and then I have another
operation that's more reconstruction to
finish off um I'm on the waiting list
for that but I feel I feel I feel great
I feel like me again I feel yeah I feel
like I can do things I can't do
everything that I used to be able to do
just yet because I'm not fit enough I've
done anything for quite a while but yeah
I feel like I'm more like me if you will
indulge with this we've run out of time
but James you are the foreign secretary
and I am with my other hats on the
political editor hopefully we can do a
proper sit down on politics and foreign
policy another time but just just to ask
you because I really have to now I'm
here just on Russia and Ukraine we're at
a phase in that war where Putin's
options appear to be now heroin the
Russians are now pulling out of kyotes
near Carson are we reaching the point
now where you think Russia is losing
that war
Russia started losing this war the day
their tanks rolled across the border
because
um it was clear that Putin expected that
President zielinski would be overthrown
that he could be replaced with some kind
of puppet leader that the ukrainians
would collapse their morale would
collapse and what happened is that they
were galvanized the International
Community came together and from that
point onwards
result was inevitable which was that the
ukrainians would succeed and we're now
seeing that played out
there are of course options for for
Putin and the most I think the best
option for him is to is to withdraw uh
is to allow the ukrainians to have their
country back
um and and the reason why that's the
best option is because it's clear the
International Community the UK very much
included in that we'll continue to
support the ukrainians until they
succeed and Russia is now interested in
talking isn't it I mean yeah and in the
ultimate
um withdrawal just one more thing does
that fit for you for president zielinski
that includes Crimea does it for the UK
government as well the decision about
this has got to be for the ukrainians
it's got to be for president zielinski
you know we will we will we will
continue to support the ukrainians until
this is until this is done and we're
absolutely not going to uh and no one
should dictate to the ukrainians uh what
the what the terms of any settlement
should be that will be for the
ukrainians do and we're going to
completely we're going to support them
and you're 100 I'm I'm out of time I'm
going to ask you one cheeky final
question
okay if you don't mind
um things have carved down a lot around
this place in Westminster I spoke to you
to remember the day that Rishi sunak was
anointed conservative party leader you
had backed Boris Johnson up to that
point James you you and he go back a
long way you've always been a key Ally
to him
um but now we've kind of got back to
stability and the sort of
that that period's over did you did you
regret a bit wanting to bring back the
Boris Johnson era well as you said work
with them for over a decade
um and he supported me and I've
supported him uh but the point is he
chose not to stand that was his decision
his decision Alone
um Rishi has
I mean he's already demonstrated in what
has only been let's remind ourselves
only been a very very short time as
prime minister he's already shown
himself to be incredibly effective in
terms of putting some calmness and
stability back into the economic
situation I've just seen him at cop27
very very calm confident and assured on
the world stage I think the
Parliamentary party and and uh you know
the the The Wider party in the country
really rallying around him uh you know I
I am absolutely completely comfortable
that he is going to be an outstanding
prime minister and Susie this is about
you this interview
even though he's the foreign secretary
or the star of this show at the moment I
just want to ask you one more thing
you've been through this incredible
journey you've done it clearly with
great resilience what's for for women
out there watching this that are
suffering from breast cancer might be be
having horrible treatment right now
might be in some of the Dark Places
you're in what's your what's your
message what do you want to sort of say
to them
well use the resources there are so many
resources out there people to speak to
when I was at a really
difficult moment I rang the acute
oncology and they said to me they were
just brilliant they'd said to me you
know you're going through so much but
don't worry things will get better and
just those words just made me
all the worry and not the worry just the
anxiousness and just just dissipated
um but but the thing to do is is it will
get well hopefully we'll get better just
keep going and be positive and um
I don't know it just
I don't know stick with it it's not a
nice Journey it's a really tough road
but you know I got I went right down to
the bottom but I did did keep going and
I got back up and now I'm you know I'm
nearly there I'm nearly there so just
there's some really tough times but it
does it can it will should get better
and I'm so glad I'm so glad for both of
you and your boys thank you that you did
get through the other side so thank you
so much uh for talking to us today I was
absolutely fascinating thank you Susie
thank you James thank you thank you
James and Susie cleverly they're in
quite a different interview than I'd
normally do with a foreign secretary and
if you scan this QR code on screen now
you can watch all of our interviews
online and all of the previous episodes
of the show well stay with us because
coming up Lord McDonald instrumental in
the downfall of Boris Johnson we get his
thoughts on what it means to be a leader
and what he thinks of past PMS
foreign
sexual misconduct allegations were made
about the former deputy chief whip Chris
pincher it sent the government into
turmoil Boris Johnson the then prime
minister said he did not know about the
claims but one man Simon McDonald a
former civil servant wrote a letter
saying that he did Lord MacDonald Has
now written a book called leadership and
gives me his verdict on the leader's
past and present that he worked with
Lord McDonald thank you so much for
coming on the show and we're going to
talk a bit about this book which I'm
reading lessons about a life in
diplomacy a book on leadership and my
goodness me you've worked with quite a
few uh leaders in government you worked
at the foreign office for nearly four
decades
you were the most senior official at the
foreign office and one of the
government's top mandarins for five
years you've seen an awful lot you've
written the book about leadership in
which you talk about previous Prime
Ministers and how they handled the job
and this is a real treat for me because
typically civil servants never talk to
journalists so I'm feeling very spoiled
but of those Prime Ministers you served
who was the best and who was the worst
leader
good question bear
um and not a simple answer because they
were all good at some things and they
were all weak at some things uh and they
all or nearly all look better in the
rear view mirror so as I look back the
first one I was really conscious of was
Margaret Thatcher who was a very
difficult prickly character for the
system but who had a Clarity and a sense
of purpose and a sense of galvanizing
the system which looks to have been one
of our most effective prime ministers in
300 years then there was John Major who
at the time looked rather beleaguered
but was one of the most methodical men
I've ever seen where he went through the
breeze he knew exactly what he was going
to say in any international meeting and
we had Blair the best at communicating
you know in retrospect some of his
biggest policy calls were just wrong but
at the time the domestic policy the
island policy was right yeah Gordon
Brown the best at fine ants but quite
a difficult Community he he bore his he
wore his anxieties on his face yeah and
when you're trying to lead people
through very difficult times to look as
though you're burdened it makes your
task more difficult uh Cameron ran a
team you know he looked the most at ease
in the job and uh he was some ways the
easiest to work for
Theresa May she was again a very
methodical person but with a very
difficult job that she didn't really
sympathize with she hadn't been a
brexiteer so that kind of hobbled her
from the start and then we had Boris
Johnson mm-hmm
okay one work okay you've given me all
these different I could give an
adjective for each of those leaders what
would be the one adjective you would
just use to describe to summarize Boris
Johnson as a leader
charismatic
okay that's a positive
negative chaotic chaotic charismatic and
chaotic Okay so we've got Thatcher as
difficult but effective we've got major
is a bit beleaguered we've got Blair the
communicator Cameron the team leader uh
Brown good at Finance but a bit anxious
and then you've got May encumbered by a
policy she didn't believe in but
methodical we've got Johnson
charismatic but chaotic who is the best
who was the worst
um Thatcher was the best and Johnson was
the worst okay
of those who've been talking what about
blur
a Blair I think will always be
remembered for Northern Ireland and the
Good Friday agreement was the single
most important agreement Within These
Isles in my lifetime but he will also be
remembered for Iraq and no matter how
much he believed in the prospectus at
the time I think looking back uh it
needs to be reappraised including by
himself let's just talk a bit if you
don't mind about Boris Johnson because
he he features in the book
um now civil servants live much of their
lives behind the scenes you don't really
talk to journalists it's kind of code of
conduct that you have to be utterly
discreet you're a diplomat I mean you
work in the shadows you'll never see
them
well did you want to be a spider if you
want to be a spy ever because I'm not
discreet enough okay but you did as a
former permanent section in fact you did
get involved in the raring golf in Boris
Johnson over the Chris pincher Affair
now just to quickly remind people this
was the deputy chief whip accused of
sexual misconduct back in July
government ministers publicly saying the
Prime Minister was unaware that he faced
such allegations in the past
um before putting him into that
sensitive job as deputy chief whip
you heard all of it what did you make of
it what did you think when you heard it
I heard it for five days uh and at the
beginning it seemed to me like a typical
number 10 operation where no matter the
problem the instant reaction was denial
uh quite adamant quite aggressive uh and
quite unbending but you know the the
pathology is this changes over time and
it did change over the following days
but they never came up with the truth
and there were two key facts which I
thought needed to be in the public
domain and which were still not in the
public domain the following Tuesday and
they were had there been allegations
before had they been investigated and
what was the outcome and second did the
Prime Minister know and the answers to
these two questions were yes and yes
because this has happened at the foreign
office yes a few years before he Chris
pincher was a junior Minister a very
similar allegation was made by members
of the foreign office they came to me
personally because it was very sensitive
and very unusual because it was
sensitive and unusual it was also very
memorable so I remembered each of the
steps I knew I kept the cabinet office
at the highest level informed and they
kept me informed about what they were
doing including with the prime minister
so the then foreign secretary Boris
Johnson was he then prime minister he
was prime minister and he was told yes
and Simon did you know the impact it
would have because it had big impact
which we'll get to did you appreciate at
the time when you made the intervention
this is going to be big frankly no you
didn't okay the last words I said to my
wife before I went to bed because my
wife made me sleep on it I'd written the
letter on the Monday evening she made me
sleep on it and as we were going to
sleep I said do you think anybody will
notice
well they did notice and his cabinet
notes which I'll come to but you then
found yourself a victim with quite a
vicious brief in war this is uh from The
Daily Telegraph on the 5th of July the
the morning the day that you released
this letter saying that it's not true
what number 10 is saying about what the
PM did and didn't know this is a former
minister they never saw eye to eye Simon
never made a secret the fact he was a
strong remainer and he has always had
big issues with brexit so now they're
playing the man not the ball there was a
sense that this was some sort of revenge
on your part or you had issues with
Boris Johnson the lead in brexiteer what
what would you say to those allegations
how did that feel for you is it really
unpleasant it was unpleasant but much
less unpleasant than what the victims of
the various Pinscher scandals had
undergone
um uh and it was wrong and I knew it was
wrong I mean I have already said I was a
remainer and I made that plane to the
then foreign secretary and prime
minister but what was more important was
doing the job for the government and I
believe I did that and the foreign
office did that but but someone was
there any extent to which you were
opposed to his political project and you
did want to get rid of him no
absolutely not uh I I hope I'm smiling
because the idea that civil servants sit
around and plot who should be in charge
is just not true but but you didn't like
I mean the book trips with animosity I
have to say and you you didn't like the
guy right you didn't think he was up to
the job that's fair isn't it they're two
different points Beth uh on a personal
level Boris Johnson was always
Charming to deal with he was humorous he
was kind he was the person the foreign
secretary I worked with Who had most
time for the people in his office
including in his outer office and this
is a real Mark of a character but what
you Need to Be an Effective prime
minister is different being prime
minister is one of the toughest jobs in
the world and one of the surprises to me
is that in modern British politics so
many people think they are qualified to
pitch for this most difficult and most
examining of job and he wasn't in your
view qualified I other people will judge
but I think as he contemplates his three
years as prime minister he probably
would concede that he did not achieve
what he hopes it's like so you said I
mean extremely charismatic and he he
genuinely is a charismatic leader who
can reach parts of the lecturer you know
that other concern loved his can't reach
other politicians can't reach he said he
was chaotic
what other traits did you see in him
that made you think this is a really
hard job and you're not up to it so
chaotic what else the chaotic was he
liked to have multiple opinions swirling
around him and then and the people
proposing those ideas never really knew
whose was in the lead and where the
decision would be and sometimes the
decision wasn't clear and sometimes the
decision was reversed so there was a
there was too much swirl and in the end
the the system responds to clearer
Direction but your your intervention was
decisive you you are the civil servant
that brought down a prime minister I
mean the resignation started that night
from his cabinet you are you are I am
I'm a footnote uh my history teacher who
features in the book told me the
difference between the occasion of
events and the causes of events the
causes that brought down Boris Johnson
had been laid long before my tweet okay
so you say you weren't the cause that
you know you you know you weren't the
cause you were the occasion I I read
that in the book but you were still the
trigger okay
you accept that I accept that mine was
the final straw that made it onto the
Johnson's camels back first but you did
open the flood date because it was after
your letter and I remember listening to
the radio that morning and thinking
blimey this is because because you don't
intervene and that you did
it did trigger a series of events in
which both sad to Javed and then Rishi
sunak resigned from cabinet that night
then dozens more resignations by
Wednesday night the Prime Minister
insisted he was going to stay Thursday
morning he had no option
um but to go but Beth all I did was
insist on two facts to be acknowledged
and the fact that they had not been
acknowledged for the previous five days
turned out to be important and but you
then tweeted out if you you tweeted out
a picture of Westminster at Sunset and
you said it had been you you mentioned
in the book it's been a good day there
we go that there it was a good day
um it did make it sound like a personal
animus a bit I that you you had your
reasons he pushed you out of the foreign
office he chose to merge the Departments
I mean it was pretty brutal the way you
got shoved out after a very long and
successful career
I supported the merger very very
strongly now Beth as I look at that
tweet uh and think about all the
reactions that is something I would do
differently ah okay but at the time I
was reacting to the negative briefing
right you know the whole system
everything around the Prime Minister had
become so personal and disagreeable so
that in that moment with that rather
lovely view it did feel like so it was a
good day so you so the personal
briefings did get you a bit and you did
this Did you sort of wish you hadn't
done this now well you said you do it
differently I would
um because
uh I didn't want it to be personal it
wasn't personal I was trying to
establish important facts and the fact
that that tweet obscures that
um uh means that I misfired but it also
shows that you were heart hurt and human
yeah yeah heart and human and had
horrible briefings against you before we
move on though
um
what were you thinking when it looked
like Boris Johnson was potentially going
to return as prime minister over that
weekend where it looked like he was
going to make another Tilt at the job
were you were you alarmed by that yes
um
it just seemed incredible to me that
people who had lived through all of 2022
who had lived through that dramatic week
in July who had precipitated Boris
Johnson's downfall so the Parliamentary
conservative party would just three or
four months later forget all the
negative side and think you know we'll
give him a second chance and the thing
that most puzzled me was the line that
Boris Johnson has learned his lesson
whereas one thing I think Boris Johnson
has always been clear and consistent
about is that he is who he is you take
him as he is and he does not and will
not change
so I was very surprised that uh more
than a hundred conservative MPS had
forgotten that but should there ever be
a way back for him or you think not of
course they can be of course another
tilt
um I quote Enoch Powell and others that
there are no second acts in British
politics so it would be a surprise but
he has that option it would take a lot
of hard work and he would have to put
other priorities on hold so he wouldn't
be able to devote so much time to the
speaker circuit in the USA he'd have to
devote a lot of time to his constituency
and to Parliament and now we have
or we had less trust I mean you say in
the book that you'd hoped that civility
honesty and personal responsive
responsibility would come with the
arrival of a new prime minister what did
you make of Liz truss's short
Premiership were you
what was your view of how you you'd work
with her before as well hadn't you only
at one remove and our conversation about
good Prime Ministers ended too soon or
bad Prime Ministers I think if the list
includes Liz trusswell then she was the
worst prime minister than Boris Johnson
because she started and made two
immediate irrevocable mistakes the first
was excluding from her government
anybody who had not supported her to the
hilt and the second was running a budget
a mini budget that was ideologically
driven and before launching that budget
taking care that she could not hear
would not receive any contrary advice
you Boris Johnson also did that by the
way he he put into cabinet he he created
a government around him that were full
of his backers and not his
detractors
true but he had led the party to its
biggest election victory since Margaret
Thatcher Liz truss had not one thing she
did do that was she did secure the
release of nazneen zagari Radcliffe now
did she ride on the success of others
hard work successive or her predecessors
or was she genuinely a politician that
could get things done she pays tribute
to the work of her predecessors I mean
Jeremy Hunt in particular devoted
himself to nazanin zagari Radcliffe's
case so it was the culmination of a lot
of people's hard work and Liz trust was
there when the moment came just quickly
before I move on
um all of this talk in the run-up to
this moment where Liz trust became prime
minister they talked about treasury
Orthodoxy did you see that as code for
disregarding the civil service order did
you see it as a
a sort of sign of attack on Whitehall
well it was certainly an attack on the
treasury it was an attack on constraints
it was an attack on things that uh Liz
truss and her team believed had been
holding back the United Kingdom but they
learned very quickly that their analysis
was not a complete analysis but was
there anything more the Civil Service
could have done to avert the crisis you
know like does this also always take
some responsibility or are you merely ex
executors of your political Masters if
you like the deal is civil servants
advise and ministers to decide so all
the decisions of Liz truss's government
were hers and her ministers
well I want to just we we've partless
trust and Boris Johnson quickly Rishi
sunak where would you put him in your
your leadership uh League table
one of the methodical ones as you say
unproven but promising raw material very
promising promising okay I feel awkward
as a civil servant assassin is my
favorite things
there we go another critical from policy
issue of your time was the Iraq War and
you come pretty close in this book
saying that Tony Blair lied you you talk
about uh that moment where in the chill
cot inquiry that letters uncovered where
he says to President Bush I will be with
you whatever do you think he lied no I
think that the intelligence picture
comprehensively misled him and you're
quite critical of that I'm sure he at
every step during during the run-up and
through the conflict he believed what he
was saying because there were was
documentary evidence intelligence to
support it but but Simon you also talk
in the book about leaders the best
leaders being able to make mistakes
admit their mistakes
um with the reference to Blair's
insistent that the Iraq War was not a
disaster do you think he struggles to
admit his mistakes even now even as time
has passed yes you do I think
um there's still time for him to look
again but even all these years later he
I believe defends what he did further
than the facts support you think that
that's poor leadership
an aspect but he did many other things
what is it about him is it is it
arrogant is it arrogance is it
self-belief is it doesn't want to admit
it to himself it's a human thing the
things the decisions that are biggest in
our lives we are most attached to uh if
it turns out they were wrong decisions
it's very very difficult as a human
being to admit it and I what if you
indulge I've gone massively over time as
ever but this is such a fascinating
conversation I just want to finish on
Putin I
find this section in the book
fascinating when you talk about Tony
Blair's final G8 Summit is you're nodded
you'll know the bit I'm referring to
it's 2007 and he meets Putin and Putin
signals in this conversation a
reassertion of Russian influence and
aggression and dissatisfaction with the
post Cold War setup and the way in which
he perceives Russia has been treated or
rather sort of mistreated by the Western
those leaders 15 years ago do you think
that they ever understood the
significance of that moment or did they
ever take him seriously
they took him seriously but they
misread the signals from 2007 which
started in a big speech in Munich at the
security conference in February but then
as the year went on he he was saying
this more and more clearly and the
following year he invaded Georgia and
ever since then we have seen a ramping
up of Russian operations externally
Crimea in 2014 was enormously important
but kind of downplayed so when we look
back we in the west must see that we
contributed to him overreaching in
February 2022. is that one of your
biggest regrets when you look back on
your time in the foreign office is that
one of your biggest regrets that kind of
perhaps
Leaders The Establishment didn't see
what was coming or was it seen But for
other political reasons wasn't acted
upon we did some very good things on
Russia policy I think after the
screepile poisoning the British system
with Boris Johnson as The Foreign
secretary led the world's reaction never
before have 30 countries coordinated
expulsion of spies but when you measure
what we were doing against the challenge
that we now see well then clearly we
fell short but Beth I think this applies
in other areas of policy right now I
think we're falling short in our climate
response you know something we talk
about we know is important cop 27 is
happening right now but I suspect in 10
20 years when we look back we'll think
okay we were doing some stuff but we
really weren't doing enough is that one
area though where you think Boris
Johnson can take some credit that he did
try and galvanize
momentum on climate yeah cop 26 was the
biggest uh such conference since the
Paris uh conference in 2016 uh so all
2015. so yes he did show leadership and
it was you know the awful circumstances
of the end of the coffee that meant that
it was uh smaller and less impactful
than he wanted and and so my final
question to you
do you think that a cornered Putin might
reach for tactical nuclear weapons
I understand his rationale in spooking
us
I do not believe it works for Russia
actually to deploy such weapons they
would lose all their support starting
with most important China so I think
when Putin is looking at an actual
decision he will decide not to use
nuclear weapons what adjective would you
use to describe Putin as a leader
cold calculating
scary dangerous dangerous for sure okay
well look thank you so much Simon
McDonald Lord McDonald for coming in to
talk about your book and it was really
enjoyable to talk to you fascinate him
thank you thank you Beth thank you
Simon McDonald there and we should say
the former deputy chief whip Chris
pincher denies all allegations of sexual
misconduct
well that's it for tonight's show thank
you so much to all of our guests Lord
McDonald and James and Susie cleverley
and if you scan that QR code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
Beth Rigby interviews podcast a new
episode is available each week and I
take a look at the highlights of the
interviews and we talk a bit of politics
too that's on the Sky News app or
wherever you get your podcasts thank you
so much for watching tonight and I hope
to see you next time
[Music]